this is the ninth successive increase in
interest rates and when you kind of just
compare kind of where we are now with a
year ago that's uh up by the fastest
rate that we've seen since 1989 and that
figures obviously inflation is the
highest rate that we've seen since the
1980s as well but there is a big jolt
happening which many people around the
country are experiencing on top of
higher energy costs and this I'm afraid
will increase it if you have a mortgage
especially if it's not a fixed rate
mortgage then you're going to see that
rise instantly if you have a fixed rate
mortgage if you're coming up to refix it
then to some extent this will have
already been taken into account remember
we were talking a lot of this year about
expectations for interest rates well
that's already fed into some of those
fixed uh rate mortgage costs but when
you take a step back look at what's
happened recently we've had inflation
potentially peaking so going down from
that high rate and actually dropping a
little bit below expectations still in
double digits but nonetheless going a
little bit lower than people expected
you've got the bank of England slowing
the pace of interest rate increases and
obviously that's happening as well on
the other side of the Atlantic as well
with the Federal Reserve so you're
starting to see things slow down a
little bit and there were some glimmers
of hopes with it within the minutes that
were released with this uh with this
decision in terms of the decision by the
way it was a split decision everyone
pretty much expected that you've got
kind of nine members of this monetary
policy committee which decide on
interest rates uh six of them said yes
we'll do half a percentage Point
increase uh two of them said no actually
we want to leave things where they are
at three percent then one of them
actually said we want it even faster
than that not unexpected because we're
getting to that point now again as I say
where things are starting potentially uh
to slow down we're seeing a Slowdown in
that increase but the glimmers have also
come from the fact that when you look at
GDP so look at the rate of growth in the
economy the bank basically expected it
to look a lot worse right now than it
actually is so we're still potentially
in a recession right now it looks very
likely but it may not be quite as deep
as it previously expected and it's only
I know a little glimmer but one has to
take one what one can get after the year
that we've had and that broad picture
inflation potentially having piqued
interest rates still Rising still
causing an impact to protect
particularly if you have a mortgage but
not necessarily going up quite as fast
as they previously were maybe only
peaking at about four and a half percent
next year this is a slight Improvement
on on you know the bleakness that things
looked at the bleakness of the situation
only a few months ago